mesdames et messieurs bonsoir j'espère
que vous avez passé un bon dimanche le
temps sur la france s'améliore un peu
mais tout doucette le sommet européen de
luxembourg est un événement très
important et des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont du pain sur la planche
malgré les difficultés que connaît la
constitution de l'europe
la réunion sera dominée par la situation
internationale telle qu'elle se présente
après d'échec avant-hier de la tentative
américaine en iran c'est ce que monsieur
giscard d'estaing déclaré en substance
en arrivant à luxembourg à l'un de nos
envoyés spéciaux georges bortoli une
étrange qui concerne la situation
internationale
la france est décidée à poursuivre ses
efforts
le pente la communauté toute entière en
solidarité avec des états unis pour
obtenir la libération des otages détenus
en contradiction avec les droits de
l'homme et les l'oise internet la
gravité de la situation internationale
incitera-t-elle les européens se serrer
les coudes c'est très possible car l'on
constate depuis quelques heures que les
problèmes proprement européen en
discussions semblent évoluer dans le bon
sens et quand je dis problème européen
je pense en premier lieu à cette
épineuse question des prix agricoles
dont la solution conditionne réellement
celle de tous les autres problèmes la
position britannique sur les problèmes
agricoles s'est en effet suffisamment
assouplies pour que en marge des
arrivées spectaculaires des chefs d'état
et de gouvernement une autre conférence
plus discrète réunissent les ministres
de l'agriculture qui met les bouchées
doubles pour ébaucher un accord les
allemands poussent au compromis
répondant aux directives du chancelier
schmitt et le ministre français monsieur
ben helli a confié à philippe sassier
qu'il était plutôt confiant et déjà un
début de compromis en ce qui concerne la
hausse des prix agricoles on parle
notamment d'une augmentation qui se
situerait autour de 4 est née % non
compte tenu de la dévaluation du franc
vers il y à des délégations qui se situe
à 4 % d'autres acat ennemis et quatre ou
cinq délégations à sac
voilà exactement la situation actuelle
au niveau des prix en unités de compte
pour la délégation française rassemble
dont la délégation française étant
entendu que nous souhaitons nous
rapprocher le plus possible d'une
augmentation de prix à deux chiffres
avec les montants compensatoires
monétaire c'est à dire que les positions
sont quand même beaucoup rapprochée de
la position française
les délégations sont toutes conscientes
dans leur grande majorité qu'il y ait un
vrai problème aujourd'hui au sein des 8
millions d'agriculteurs de la communauté
compte tenu des conséquences de la crise
de l'énergie sur l'ensemble des coûts de
production füle matériel engrais
madame thatcher acceptera-t-elle de
revenir de luxembourg avec selon sa
propre expression
une demie miche de pain à la place d'une
miche de pain entière c'est-à-dire
acceptera t'elle un compromis en tout
cas si la sphère agricole est
effectivement réglés
on va pouvoir aborder la demande des
britanniques d'alléger leur contribution
financière au budget européen et on peut
nourrir quelques espoirs compte tenu de
la volonté politique d'aboutir à un
accord
chacun comprend ici que dans la crise
internationale
l'europe doit être présente et solidaire
voilà donc une note légèrement plus
optimiste qui permet d'espérer un
déblocage des difficultés entre les
partenaires hors pair par ailleurs le
bruit circule mais ce n'est qu'un bruit
et luxembourg que sur proposition
britannique les neuf demandes réparé
rencontrer très rapidement messieurs
carter et sans attendre en tout cas la
réunion des pays occidentaux prévu pour
le mois de juin avec en iran des auteurs
américains sont dispersés comme l'avait
annoncé dès hier soir et l'arménie un
certain nombre d'entre eux vont être
envoyés dans la province de
l'azerbaïdjan au nord-ouest du pays
d'autres du temps à qom la ville sainte
partout ils seront confiés par les
étudiants islamiques à la vigilance des
autorités municipales
une manière comme une autre de dire
regardez les bien et surtout qu on avoue
des élèves pas quant au coeur des
américains tombés au cours de
l'opération il ya deux jours et abbas
ils ont été ramenés à terrain notre
envoyé spécial bernard benyamin y
assistent
des drapeaux iraniens et huit corps ceux
des huit américains morts dans le désert
voilà tout ce qui reste du raid manqué
des états unis sur l'iran depuis hier
soir la télévision iranienne pas cette
image dans toutes les éditions est bien
la preuve de l'échec américain est bien
la main de dieu est sûre nous déclare le
commentateur
voilà le sort qu'a la réserve à nos
ennemis une nouvelle fois en tout cas
unité du pays s'est refaite les
divisions internes sont oubliées oublier
aussi la menace du manque
d'approvisionnement des produits
alimentaires l'échec du raid américain
arrange tout le monde en iran reste à
savoir pour combien de temps cet après
midi en tout cas cette présentation des
corps à l'ambassade américaine
cela peut-être galvaniser les foules en
levant elle était surtout morbide et
sordide pour tous les journalistes
présents à téhéran une autre information
nous étaient parvenues vers midi à
terrain on y annonce et d'un coup d'état
dans un pays voisin l'irak avec lequel
l'iran vous savez en conflit on disait
que le président irakien mais ce sésame
hussein avaient été tués dans un coup
d'état
voilà qui aurait pu avoir de très graves
conséquences internationales
mais vingt minutes plus tard les
démentis afflué de partout et selon
bagdad
la vie se déroule près normalement en et
tchad
le gouvernement français a décidé de
mettre en oeuvre sa décision de retirer
les forces militaires françaises selon
un communiqué de l'elysée les forces
françaises ayant accompli leur mission
de protection
le retrait est effectuée en vertu des
accords pris avec le gouvernement de
l'union nationale du tchad et il tiendra
compte des préoccupations du
gouvernement tchadien
tandis que de ne jamais n'at on apprend
qu'un conseil des ministres a destitué
pour cause de rébellion le ceis n abrite
quelques précisions par service faire
un millier de soldats français vont
quitter le tchad incessamment divers
accords de coopération et l'aide
militaires conclus avec les
gouvernements de ce pays les y avait
retenu c'est avec le départ de ses
hommes la fin définitive de la présence
française au tchad
une présence qui remonte à 10 897 date
de l'arrivée des premiers français lors
des récents combats qui se sont déroulés
entre les diverses factions armées de
goukouni oueddei hissène habré les
troupes françaises ont observé une
stricte neutralité se bornant à protéger
les civils français et européens se
trouvant sur place et soignant les
blessés
après avoir organisé l'évacuation de ces
civils et de leur famille ou du moins
ceux qui voulaient partir
l'elysée a estimé dans un communiqué
publié cet après midi que ses forces
militaires avaient accompli leur mission
de protection leur retrait a donc été
décidé ce retrait se fera selon des
modalités fixées en accord avec le
gouvernement du tchad une confirmation
de ce que vous lisez tout hébert losc à
terme et à openoffice dire leur
carrington avec l'arrêt aujourd'hui
qu'il y avait une possibilité de réunir
un sommet occidentale sur l'iran avec
que le président carter cette
possibilité pourrait être discutée au
cours de l'entretien au coin du feu que
des neuf chefs d'état et de gouvernement
auront l'heur de leur dîner traditionnel
où l'on peut être dès maintenant s'ils
se sont déjà mis à table à strass
est ce la fin de la prise d'otages en
colombie dans la capitale bogota vous le
savez un commando de guérilleros ce
retrait depuis février 18 diplomate à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade de la
république dominicaine en colombie cet
après midi après de très longs
pourparlers
le commando a quitté les lieux en
emmenant avec lui tresse diplomates dont
huit ambassadeurs l'appareil est parti
pour la havane où l'on espère que les
otages seront relâchés puis les
guérilleros ce s'envoleront dit on pour
la libye en tous les cas ils n'ont pas
obtenu avant de quitter bogota la
libération des trois sens plénier
politique qu'il réclamait depuis 2
à paris la convention du parti
socialiste a fixé le calendrier pour la
procédure de désignation du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle l'an prochain
ce vin congrès national qui prendra la
décision le 14 décembre
et c'est donc ce jour-là que le candidat
socialiste sera connu dès ce matin
monsieur chevénement annoncé qu'il
serait candidat
si et monsieur mitterrand ne l'était pas
l'oreille copains comme elles ont lieu
aujourd'hui les intentions de monsieur
conso mitterrand premiers secrétaires du
ps si bien dire on ne sait toujours pas
enfin pas vraiment à la sortie de la
convention tout à l'heure des
socialistes me disais maintenant c'est
clair françois mitterrand sera candidat
et d'autres me disais maintenant c'est
clair françois mitterrand n'est plus
candidat le parti socialiste va dire
donne un peu l'impression d'un parti qui
vit au conditionnel vous le disiez à
l'instant
jean pierre chevènement a annoncé qu'il
était candidat ou plus exactement qu'il
serait candidat
si françois mitterrand ne l'était pas
depuis un an michel rocard répète qu'il
ne serait pas candidat lui-même
si françois mitterrand était candidat et
depuis quelques semaines pierre mauroy
annonce qu'il soutiendrait michel rocard
si françois mitterrand n'était pas
candidat tout tourne donc autour de
françois mitterrand qui me semble-t-il
s'amuse un peu de cette situation et qui
en tout cas entretient le doute
volontairement et je crois politique et
chers camarades je ne suis pas candidat
et que signifie dès lors cette ces
danses du ventre autour de moi cette
volonté à tout prix veut dire présente
pas surreprésentés on se présente si
vous présentez pas on préfère celui ci
qu'est ce que je dis moi bien françois
mitterrand n'a pas dit je ne serai pas
candidat mais je ne suis pas candidat
sous-entendu bien sûr pour l'instant il
se prononce en fait vous allez
l'entendre pour un autre type de
candidature
je suis candidat pour le rassemblement
des travailleurs
ensuite pour le rassemblement des
français autour du socialisme que nous
représentons tout autre choix toute
autre décision toute autre candidature
n'a pas de sens si elle implique
quelques contradictions que ce soit avec
cette tâche essentielle mais le copain
commun comprenez vous cela à quoi le
premier secrétaires sera-t-il gold est
bien seul et je crois que là il faut
peut-être plutôt que de candidature
parler de mission ou de vocation
françois mitterrand le patron du ps il
affirme d'ailleurs hautement il fait des
remontrances à michel rocard et même à
d'autres sur un ton qui est quelquefois
paternel et quelquefois à 6 acide mais
surtout patron du parti socialiste qu'il
entend être le garant de l'unité de ce
parti il entend être aussi le garant de
la ligne de ce parti est le symbole
d'une certaine idée du socialisme
cette vocation ou alors si l'on veut
comme le dit françois mitterrand cette
candidature prend je crois dans son
esprit une sorte de dimension historique
en tout cas elle dépasse l'échéance des
élections présidentielles mais elle
n'est pas j'ajouterai même bien au
contraire en contradiction avec une
candidature aux présidentielles
il est clair que pour françois
mitterrand le candidat du parti
socialiste doit exprimer cette ligne
politique que lui-même défend françois
mitterrand a je crois marquer des points
aujourd'hui
devant cette convention qui au départ
dès hier ils étaient majoritairement
favorables mais d'ici le mois de
décembre
il y aura sans doute encore une
compétition assez vive dans les rangs du
parti socialiste s'est dit aujourd'hui
la journée de la déportation en souvenir
les innombrables français de toutes
origines et de toutes confessions qui
furent envoyés par l'occupant nazi dans
les camps de concentration
deux cent trente mille furent déportés
200 millimes augure
monsieur giscard d'estaing a assisté ce
matin avant de partir au luxembourg à la
messe que présidait le car démarre
si pour ce 35e anniversaire de la
libération des camps de concentration
le président de la république était
procuré de très nombreuses personnalités
gouvernementales municipal militaires et
religieuses d'autres célébrations ont eu
lieu au mémorial des déportés inconnu
puis au mémorial de la france
combattante au mont valérien près de
paris
chacun pensait à ceux qui furent les
victimes de la barbarie déchaînés et
notamment à la clairière des fusillés ou
le docteur plantier secrétaires d'état
aux anciens combattants à la s'incliner
c'est la première fois depuis de longues
années me semble-t-il qu'une caméra est
admise dans la clairière aujourd'hui ou
pavillon de paris à la porte de pantin
se tenait comme tous les ans la
manifestation dès 12h pour israël un
ensemble de spectacles de discussions
politiques mais cette année le politique
dominer un commentaire de maurice faire
taire
c'est d'abord une fête avec ses idoles
enrico macias bien sûr à payer par
amadou c'est la foule des jours de fête
plus de cent mille spectateurs
participants dit aux organisateurs une
atmosphère bon enfant très militaire à
mienne mais aussi omniprésent les thèmes
politiques et la présence d'hommes
politiques comme le fera sans
interrompre son vol en un instant on
veut beaucoup c'est un politique
dominant cette année le plus nouveau le
plus répété mais qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité c'est celui du renouveau
juif pour l'essentiel en désaccord avec
la politique énoncée par exemple la
république lors de son récent voyage
dans les émirats du golfe persique
à propos des droits il fallait ce qui
n'est que nous lui disons que c'est là
le groupe de jeunes actuels en france de
jeunes juifs qui veut prendre la volée
qui veut démontrer que le judaïsme est
une force en france et qui veut montrer
au gouvernement que nous ne nous
laisserons pas faire nous laisserons pas
sacrifier l'état d'israël
nous sommes de bons français mais
lorsque les intérêts d'une vraie sont en
danger
les juifs ne me trompe peut-être pas
pour giscard si jusqu'à ne change pas sa
politique
je pense que ce n'est pas très efficace
sur les je pense que il faut que toute
la politique changer les gens pensent
que comme ça j'en ai besoin au niveau
national
niveau particulier et particularistes
suis personnellement tant que juive mais
je mets refus de consigner je pense pas
en recevoir
et je pense pas qu'on m'en donne je
pense qu'on pouvait avoir un lobby juif
et que compte tenu de la situation
politique en france est important les
élections vont se jouer sur très peu de
voix il n'y a aucune raison que les
justes ne manifestent pas nous leur
mécontentement à la politique
gouvernementale en ce moment quel que
soit leur point de vue politique
personnel recrutement de l'udf
est-ce que vous avez créé la création
d'un lob 12 juil
andy
pas que je le dis si on peut appeler ça
ne déçurent artistes gardien
trezeguet collectif qui sont représentés
en tant que jeu
et je vois pas ce qui me sépare des
autres apprécié voir
politique bien sûr mais aussi la fête et
pas seulement les chanteurs a défilé de
mannequins présentent la mode
israélienne y compris son son aspect le
plus rafraîchissant
l'été approche demain nous vous
présenterons des programmes
exceptionnels de moscou en effet que
seront diffusés en temps de midi
le journal télévisé de 20h et le
magazine question de temps comment vit
popov le soviétique moyen est il au
courant de tout ce qui se passe dans le
monde s'est-il ce que pensent les pays
occidentaux événements comme ceux
d'afghanistan se dire en sait-il popov
la position de nombreux grands pays dans
le boycott des jeux olympiques l'équipe
d'antenne 2 encore en jacca bouchard a
préparé toute une série de reportages
qui vous seront présentés par jean
pierre elkabbach et patrick poivre
d'arvor
à l'heure où le monde connaît tant de
fissures temps de soubresauts à l'heure
où un peu partout on se pose des
questions sur les intentions soviétique
les envoyés spéciaux d'antenne 2
poseront leurs questions aux soviétiques
eux mêmes
paris la grève du nettoyage du métro en
est au 35e jour elle est suivie par 900
travailleurs tous immigrés maghrébins
maliens sénégalais et mauritaniens ce
sont les employés des entreprises
auxquelles la ratp a sous traité comme
l'on dit son budget nettoyage
ces 900 travailleurs ont une tâche
beaucoup plus ardue que le public
imagine généralement et leurs conditions
d'existence sont très difficile surtout
pour un ré grève
et puis il ya les conséquences
c'est-à-dire ma santé qui s'accumulent
un reportage de martine laroche joubert
et effraie diocèse dans les entrepôts du
métro ce soir les bidon d'acide de
produits nettoyants restent sur le
carreau
sous l'autorité du chef d'equipe du
secteur les nettoyeurs du métro vont
prendre leur tour de grève dans les
piquets de grève la grève la plus longue
de leur histoire déjà plus d'un mois un
mois pour obtenir enfin la ratp a cédé
sur ce point le droit d'utiliser la
cantine et les douches du métro pouvoir
se laver après huit heures de travail en
sous sol s'il n'est pas un luxe
le balayage ne constitue qu'une partie
de la tâche pour le reste il faut
vraiment se salir les mains car les
méthodes employées sont loin d'être
moderne
le balayage balayage balayage et jusqu'à
minuit
je suis pas timide hausse et les carole
créé à partir à partir d une heure tout
le programme
croyant soit ya dix premiers
l'acide qui plaît pour la boue qui a
dans les caniveaux sa tombe d'année
6 il y en a un peu partout vos vous
défier ses amis et quelques fois vous
devez descendre muller toujours
aujourd'hui la leçon et avec cela que le
baklava ce décès avait clos son sac la
base on nettoie les cadeaux on descend
pour ramasser tous des papiers dès
qu'ils sont les 100 da ouais j'ai même
les mégots damas avec les le courant
après une fois de temps en temps n'est
pas coupé et puis le plupart du temps il
n'est pas couper le courant
d'ailleurs un accident mais ça fait
longtemps qu'il est inquiétant c'est le
truc
voilà une brosse oui si l abîme à
l'ombre de la statue de jaurès tous les
matins à la bourse du travail
les nettoyeurs qui est une assemblée
générale avant la grève il gagnait
environ 2300 francs par mois un salaire
horaire inférieur au smic
il demande aujourd'hui un treizième mois
le passage de la prime de sous sol de 1
à 6 francs et un salaire de 2800 francs
au 1er janvier 81
ils ont obtenu pour le moment une
certaine garantie de leur emploi et 2600
francs par mois
les patrons ne semblent pas disposés à
leur donner davantage les nettoyeurs eux
paraissent décidés à poursuivre leur
grève tant qu'ils n'auront pas obtenu
satisfaction
victoire amère victoire pour les
nettoyeurs du métro quand on s'appelle
moussa amadou harouna on a pas
d'économie et la grève
c'est un salaire qui disparaît c'est à
tunisiens nous a conduits chez lui sa
femme et à tunis avec quatre de ses
enfants lui il vit ici depuis 71 avec
ses trois fils dans quelques mètres
carrés sans eau chaude ni chauffage
un seul cabinet de toilette pour cinq
étages et pour ces quelques mètres
carrés des touches on lui demanda loyers
qui lui enlève le cas de son salaire
vous payez combien ici pour les loyers
cov 160 bus par mois et vous gagnez
combien partir de 2002 des mille francs
cézanne part difficilement le français
il ne sait ni lire ni écrire comme de
nombreux nettoyeur du mettront de
faibles moyens pour se défendre
un manque d'argent cruel la peur d'être
expulsé et pourtant ils se sont lancés
dans la graine en les côtoyant dans leur
appartement comme chez cézanne ou dans
les foyers d'immigrés où ils viennent
s'entasser on a le sentiment que cette
grève leur coûte cher mais qu'il ne
pouvait plus faire autrement
diarra et traoré du même village au mali
son parti le même jour pour aller
s'enfoncer dans la nuit du métro
parisien et vous habitez dans cette
chance vous êtes combien dans cette
chambre et vous payez combien ça fait
des 170 pour chacun et ça fait quatre
semaines que vous êtes en grève
vous vivez avec quoi comme argent parce
que la plupart sans appel
que le duo ou comment qu est-ce qu il ya
par exemple d'autres d'autres maliens
ici qui nous prêtent de l'argent dans le
foyer ou wii avec les favoris
est-ce que vous pensez que les français
qui prennent le métro sont d'accord avec
vous dans cette grève d'accord parce que
souvent tout le temps il donne beaucoup
de soldats
diarra traoré les autres se sentent un
peu comme cette balle de baby foot
chacun cela renvoie airs atp société des
toits y âge ministère des transports
ville de paris mais comme cette balle
c'est eux qui prennent les coûts sans
chef-d'oeuvre du patrimoine français
voilà ce que nous vous proposerons au
cours d'un week-end à l'occasion de
l'année du patrimoine nous ouvrons cette
série avec la tapisserie de bayeux
la première bande dessinée de l'histoire
en sommes et qui évoque la conquête de
l'angleterre par guillaume le conquérant
on a longtemps cru que c'était la reine
mathilde épouse de guillaume qui avait
bradé la tapisserie pour raconter les
hauts faits de son seigneur et maître de
son époux héros on sait aujourd'hui que
cet hôte dont l'évêque de bayeux et
frère du roi qu'il avait commandé à ces
brodeuses
en tout cas la tapisserie est une
fresque dans l'historienne régine
pernoud nous parle avec enthousiasme
qu'elle met dans tous ses livres mais
d'abord rue bériault nous raconte la
naissance la genèse d'élite et les sens
chez neuf que nous vous proposons
pendant un an dans les journaux du
samedi et du dimanche ont été
sélectionnés dans le cadre de l'année du
patrimoine par un jury composé de
personnalités du monde artistique et
culturelle et je dirais que cette
sélection correspond à des coups de
coeur à une sorte d'histoire d'amour
entre ceux qui vous présenteront ces
chefs-d'oeuvre et les heures elle-même
alors vous allez me dire pourquoi des
chefs-d'oeuvre du passé dans une
émission d'actualité
et bien parce que pour jean pierre
elkabbach moi même la rédaction
d'antenne 2 on ne peut pas séparer le
passé du présent et de l'avenir parce
que à travers ses chefs-d'oeuvre nous
allons découvrir notre génie notre
tempérament notre caractère
et c'est tout cela qui peut mieux nous
faire comprendre qui nous sommes
pourquoi nous agissons et quelles
raisons nous avons d'être et d'exister
où
du
ni
où
tous
70 mètres de long
cette tapisserie quelques 15 son
personnage ou animaux elle nous raconte
les divers épisodes de la conquête de
l'angleterre par guillaume le conquérant
en 1066 et on est certain qu elle a été
exécutée aux alentours de 1070 donc
presque contemporaine de l'événement ce
qui est très amusant pour nous c'est que
c'est une véritable bande dessinée du
11e siècle avec non seulement les
personnages stylisés bien sûr dans le
mode de l'époque mais aussi d'émotion
qui souligne tout ce qu'ils disent tous
qu'ils font comme les bulles de nos
bandes dessinées quelque part présente
et bien c'est toute une histoire
voyez guillaume le duc de normandie a
reçu la visite de harold un seigneur
anglais qui lui a dit vous serez roi
d'angleterre savoir où commence par
aller enfin en pèlerinage au mont saint
michel saint tellement sa mission et
puis il leur arrive une mésaventure au
moment où il franchit ce fleuve les
soldats de la suite de guillaume manque
sous l'isie dans les sables mouvants et
harold qui est très favoris c'est avec
ces grandes tâches est en trêve de
rescapés deux des seigneurs de la suite
de guillaume ensuite qu'à parader
reprenne angleterre ils apprennent
guillaume il s'est fait kuranyi roi
d'angleterre à sa place
ici c'est une merveilleuse fresque de la
vie quotidienne à laquelle nous
assistons lorsque j'étudiais les croiser
dans leur vie de tous les jours je m'en
étais beaucoup servi parce que nous
voyons
tour à tour le moment où l'on construit
les barques et tous les instruments du
bus show du charpentier de celui qui
écrit les bois ensuite on voit comment
ces barques sont traînés sur la mer et y
comment on y installe tous les objets
d'équipement voici les cotes de mailles
comporte sur un bateau d'une sorte de
portemanteaux du temps les hits et qu'on
empêche le vin qu'on a gardé d'oublier
les casques année l'onf ces chariots
haruki nous montre les astronautes
traction à leurs employés et un peu plus
loin on les verra s'embarquer pour
gagner l'angleterre et c'est la moche
mais alors que s'est-il passé
eh bien guillaume avait passé la mer
s'alarmer a rencontré celle de harold
ils se sont battus voyez nous sommes ici
en pleine bagarre
regardez même dans le bas tous ces
hommes étendu ses têtes coupées six
chevaux massacrés c'est que fracassi
et puis harold institué guillot se fait
couronner roi d'angleterre et depuis
cette époque là depuis cette bataille de
rester 14 octobre 1066
on l'a appelé guillaume le conquérant
ici vous voyez où votre et du comment
travailler ses bras deux essais brodeur
parce que la broderie à l'époque c'est
aussi bien métier d'homme qu'aux métiers
de femmes
voyez ils ont tiré des films de chaînes
des villes de tram pile réseau fixe et
les uns après les autres par un simple
petit point et il avait un air
extraordinaire c'est brad à le garder il
n'y a pas beaucoup de couleurs si vous
voulez comptez vous en trouverez
peut-être 6 ou 7 mai réalité à chaque
instant les effets se multiplient par
les rapports de couleur vous avez un
cheval vers un chemin rouge
la crinière peut-être blanche peut-être
rouge elle même sur un cheval belge etc
aujourd'hui ce serait très difficile de
d'imaginer un événement récent
transposer avec des moyens propres
l'artistique évidemment il ya eu un pic
à sion qui a pas garni qu'à mais c'est
tout de même assez exceptionnel
mais ne laissant les shows guillaume de
falaise dit le conquérant et location à
ceux de longchamp le tiercé été enlevés
dans le prix de notre confrère week end
par l'extrême accédèrent match à qui
porte le plus petit poids devant le
favori dans ce grand et le plus gros
poids le chien voici des instants
décisifs de la course au bas de la
descente à gauche en rouge strict popov
qui va entrer un terme à ma ligne droite
avec à ses côtés cayzac très clair le
favori dancing g fondé par saint martin
est en pleine piste kifissia predica
l'accord du kazakh vert foncé progresse
celle de strongle sa 300 mètres du
poteau
ces couches guère davantage mais saint
martin sur 25 g porte son attaque pour
la pro à 4 5 chevaux de front en pleine
piste un cheval grid le gros bois il
s'agit de le chesne saint-martin
décramponne sirigu et résiste à toutes
les attaques
et voici que du sein du peloton arrivant
casa coin l'extrême un thé vert matcha
délaissé à près de 50 contre 1 malgré
trois excellentes performances récentes
et cette petite jument entraînée par
jean daumas et montée par le jeune
guerrier va arracher à 25 g ta victoire
dans la dernière foulée le gris le chien
garde la troisième place pourquoi les
périodes ont-ils abandonné match a
depuis le 1er mars elle comptait une
victoire et deux places de deuxième
allez savoir en tout cas voici aînés
rapport de ces tirs s'est noyé c'est un
gros tiercé dans l'ordre 31 1471 et dans
un ordre différent 4700 et des
poussières s'est passé un peu vite la
météo demain les nuages resteront
abondant et parfois accompagnés de
pluies éparses sur le nord est de me
reste ailleurs des éclaircies se
développeront
elles seront particulièrement belle au
sud de la bretagne aux pyrénées et aux
régions méditerranéennes
notre dernier journal vous sera présenté
par gérard holtz et demain n'oubliez pas
antennes 2010 le journal de 20h est
question de temps après le journal
présenté de moscou vous saurez tout ou
presque tout sur l'urss actuelle bonsoir
merci